if you are looking to engage in just
reasonable discussions about politics
you can do that on the David Pakman show
subreddit at david pakman.com slash our
EDD i.t nearly 5,500 of our viewers and
listeners now are regularly
participating in discussions about
what's on the show what they'd like to
see on the show general politics and
this morning I was browsing the
subreddit and found a couple of
interesting posts I wanted to call to
your attention the first of which asked
whether Melania Trump is trolling Donald
Trump a user on our subreddit pointed
out that Melania
apparently favorited a tweet saying that
the only wall Trump has managed to build
is the one between him and Melania and
there's actually if you look into it
there's a couple of a series of
interesting things happening with
Melania Trump Twitter account including
I guess that she follows I think she
follows Barack Obama anyway well people
have been that that alone doesn't really
tell us anything but people have been
analyzing her Twitter account and
finding all of these sort of subtle
things that yes she may be in a sort of
held captive scenario here not only his
first lady of the United States but as
as the wife of Donald Trump and I listen
I don't know but it's starting to become
I don't believe in endless coincidences
like this there's definitely something
interesting going on about her Twitter
activity yeah and I think the act of
Melania Trump a supermodel world famous
supermodel yeah
marrying Donald Trump was an act of
trolling and a half itself right you
don't necessarily need to micro analyze
her Twitter account to think that there
might be some factors that explain why
an Eastern European model would be
married to Donald Trump I know that it's
easy to just say well yeah the factor is
called trumps bank account and there's
probably a lot to that maybe it's love
it could be that that would be one of
money that would be the most lovely
explanation I guess also from our
subreddit there is a couple of
discussions and this is just one of them
about Jordan Peterson and this
particular poster says that Jordan
Peterson is really a postmodernist
right wing
social justice warrior himself and that
he's capitalized on the white grievance
industry perpetuated by the far-right
listen I I don't want to turn this into
just bash Jordan Peterson he's been on
the program I found him to be an
interesting guy but I do think that he
has become one of these darlings of a
very particular enclave of the internet
that wants to feel good about making
good about passing certain judgments
about groups of people and they sort of
see the work of those like Jordan
Peterson as its justifying their
positions and listen Jordan Peterson
does have some interesting material
related to psychology but I overall am
not a fan of the guy and I find a lot of
his work to be very very destructive
destructive and deceptive and a lot of
people are getting lulled by it and by
his I guess we would say he has pretty
good public speaking skills and I just
think the guy is part of this broader
internet movement that is not good would
you have him on again making his rounds
in the media I would and he has a new
book out so I think you would come back
on he might be too big for the David
Pakman show now no I don't know I don't
know that he would be interested in
being back on participate in that
discussion also an article posted to our
subreddit
yikes Duterte orders soldiers to shoot
women in the vagina this is an insane
report and insane not in that it's
untrue it appears to actually be an
accurate report advise that Filipino
leader Rodrigo Duterte among the long
list of bizarre and depraved calls to
action that he has issued has ordered
soldiers to shoot women in the vagina if
they have and I don't remember if this
is related to drug dealing or using or
what it was but this guy is unhinged and
it is particularly notable that he is
one of the few people that actually
seems to be more in line with sort of
Donald Trump's authoritarian tendencies
at least only Donald Trump wanted to
grab women there yeah that's right
Trump wasn't advocating shooting women
in that spot and lastly from the David
Pakman show subreddit fundraising idea
David
eats a burger a few months ago David
described on the show how he eats a
burger upside down so here's an idea a
2,300 patreon supporter
David wood will eat a burger like this
on the show it can and actually should
be a vegan burger it's silly but not
much sillier than the crazy hair and the
Jenga I would be willing to do that the
problem with anything like that is
keeping it like a burger to be good
you need the buns to have been just
slightly warmed over but you can't warm
them in a microwave because then I just
get soggy and the entire thing needs to
have been assembled just before eating
it because otherwise the bread will also
get soggy we don't really have the
facilities here in the studio in order
to have a we have a burger delivered and
then I would eat it I think so I don't
know and if people don't remember what
that's about yeah I've described how I
sort of flip burgers when I pick them up
so that the sesame seeds end up pointing
down towards the ground and that all my
life that's how I've been eating
sandwiches and burgers and apparently
that's not yeah I don't know I don't
know if it would be that interesting
although maybe if I narrated over the
whole experience the audience would find
it fascinating uh well I'm not gonna
make an assessment about that but
certainly that that's a possibility that
could be considered I don't know about
this it's an it's an idea but I don't
know that it's one that we're gonna be
doing in any case you can join any of
these discussions or start your own by
going to david pakman.com slash read it